[Música]
[Aplausos]
y más
[Música]
les quiero proponer algo los que se
pueden parar de piel arriba todos arriba
levanten la mano derecha
ahora la mano izquierda
dos aplausos
ahora se toca la nariz
ahora le damos la mano a quien tenemos
al lado lo saludamos entre todos
bueno ya se pueden sentar
si alguien consigue pareja después me lo
agradece
imaginen que estos movimientos muy
simples y cotidianos que acaban de
realizar no lo van a poder realizar
nunca más en su vida
los invito a que me acompañen
al hospital de pediatría de la ciudad de
santa fe para hospital él hace
estamos en julio de el año 2018 y yo con
33 años
estoy dispuesto a realizar la cirugía
más compleja que aprendí
manos limpias ingresó al quirófano
la instrumentadora me ayuda a colocar la
ropa estéril
me acerco a la camilla
sobre ella el paciente ya anestesiado
ahora el campo quirúrgico
bisturí
ah me olvidaba el paciente que estoy por
operar es un bebé de 5 meses
debe operar su cuello y su axila
tiene el brazo del tamaño de mi mano
lo debo operar porque en el momento del
parto sufre una parálisis braquial
obstétrica
esto significa que los nervios que salen
del cuello que le dan movilidad y
sensibilidad a todo el miembro superior
se lesionan dejan de transmitir
información
los músculos dejan de contraerse
dejamos de sentir la piel
la lección de plexo braquial puede
afectar de diferentes maneras
la peor es una pared se completa nunca
más se moverá el hombro el codo y la
mano
el paciente que estoy por operar tuvo
una lesión un poco más benévola no movía
el hombro y el codo pero sin movía la
mano
si no lo pero esta discapacidad será
definitiva
imaginen cómo es para una persona vivir
toda su vida disponiendo de sólo una
mano hábil para atarse los cordones
atarse el pelo comer jugar
imaginen cómo sería la vida es tan así
cada vez que quiere llevar la mano
arriba de la mesa tiene que ayudarse con
otra mano pero si logra tomar un objeto
no lo puede llevar a la boca y lo puede
mantener firme para trabajar con la mano
hábil
se me cruzan muchas cosas por la cabeza
a esta cirugía ya la hice pero en
adultos es la primera vez que me toca en
un bebé
y en eso de la necesita me mira y me
dice está seguro lo que está por hacer
sí
estoy seguro de que estamos por hacer
porque mi padre profesor de cirugía en
la facultad de veterinaria desde el
chico me enseñó a operar
además me enseñó carpintería con lo cual
potencial y habilidad
me llena el camino para encontrar mi
pasión que es la cirugía
se lo que estoy por hacer porque tuve la
suerte de tener grandes profesores que
me enseñaron esto de ser cirujano en
santa fe en rosario buenos aires- san
pablo y españa- tuve la suerte de tener
grandes cirujanos que me enseñaron todo
sin pedir nada a cambio
pero ahora estoy solo
se lo que estoy por hacer
y creo tener la habilidad suficiente
porque
durante mi residencia trabajaba todos
los días de 7 a 20 3 horas de corrido
y cuando estaba de guardia 34 horas de
corrido entraba un lunes 7 de la mañana
y me iba el martes 8 de la noche
aún así encontraba el tiempo para
comprar corazón de vaca y practicar
microcirugía
yo quería tener las lupas
de microcirugía pero son muy caras se
compran en dólares entonces me las
ingenié con una lupa de plástico que
conseguí en una juguetería la mantenía
suspendida en el aire con un alambre y
una maderita parece me ayudó mucho esto
de carpintería entonces hacía foco
cortaba la coronaria de la vaca
las estudiaba y después me divertía
inyectando agua a presión y viendo cómo
pasaba el agua a través de la sutura sin
pérdidas
se lo que estoy por hacer
pero anoche dormí mal
me preguntaba todas las cosas que pueden
llegar a fallar
estoy un poco nervioso
y como no estarlo si afuera están sus
padres
los laburantes que en el momento que
me presento para iniciar la cirugía me
dan su hijo y depositan toda su
confianza en mí la responsabilidad es
muy grande
recuerdo sus ojos rojos mezcla de temor
porque entienden que se puede complicar
pero también de alegría de lo que vendrá
de que finalmente su hijo pueda volver a
mover
parte de la concentración para empezar
la cirugía es pensar en las
complicaciones debo anticipar me
evitarlas
la zona donde se realiza la intervención
es muy compleja y si me equivoco el poco
movimiento que tiene no puede perder
y si alguien del equipo quirúrgico se
equivoca
yo también soy responsable responsable
sabemos que tenemos que dar el cien por
ciento para lograr el objetivo pero si
no lo logramos
el error en medicina no se tolera y ahí
aparecen las condenas públicas que
animal cómo se va a equivocar así
y acaso nadie se equivoca
quito todas esas malas ideas de mi
cabeza
me vuelvo a concentrar
pidió al bisturí
realizó la incisión localiza la lesión y
ayudado con el microscopio que me
permite ver todo 10 20 veces más grande
futuro los nervios con un hilo muy
finito casi imperceptible a la vista
cuatro horas después de la cirugía le
devuelvo el bebé a sus padres a los
cuatro meses
alegría compartida el bebé recuperó
movilidad
les quiero contar que esta cirugía fue
la primera que se realizó en un hospital
de niños en la provincia de santa fe
[Aplausos]
[Música]
por suerte cada vez realizamos con más
frecuencia este tipo de cirugías muchos
finales felices
pero también
hay una triste realidad hay muchos niños
que han nacido que han nacido con
parálisis braquial obstétrica y no han
recibido la cirugía a su debido momento
entonces ya en la edad escolar y durante
toda su vida sufren de las secuelas
niños que no pueden mover adecuadamente
su brazo como les contaba
se puede manifestar con una parálisis
completa entonces el brazo completo no
se mueve
puede ocurrir que solamente mueva la
mano como el paciente que les conté
antes
o puede ser que tengan un poco más de
suerte y mover muy bien la mano y algo
en el brazo
lamentablemente estos niños cuando se
insertan en la de escolar no pueden
realizar muchos deportes entonces
terminé sufriendo bullying es lo peor
que le puede ocurrir el bullying porque
el poco potencial que tienen para
movilizar
no pierden si no lo estimulan al máximo
ese poco potencial lo pierden recibo mi
consultorio niños que por vergüenza
oculta en su mano no me dejan que yo se
les revise no lo ocupan en sociedad
en el caso de m
en mi gimnasio con una pared y verá que
la obstétrica y ahora tiene 10 años
su madre realizó múltiples consultas y
siempre la misma respuesta
ya no se puede hacer más nada tan mal no
está
seguramente ya sea costumbre y una
cirugía puede agravar todo
y si es verdad si la cirugía falla puede
agravar pero si va bien
a mí cuando intentaba tocar la cara
realizaba este movimiento es típico que
levantar mucho el codo para compensar
pero sólo llega al cuello y cuando
intenta derrotar externo solamente llega
acá
es decir el rango de movimiento de su
mano es este
en el realice otro tipo de cirugías y a
los dos meses ya se tocaba la cabeza o
puede abrazar un ser querido
no puedo mostrarle fotos o vídeos de mis
pacientes pero créanme que es verdad
hace unos meses recibí un reconocimiento
en la legislatura provincial por ser
pionero en esto de microcirugía en place
o braquial en hospitales públicos de la
provincia de santa fe
es un gran reconocimiento para mí un
gran estímulo para seguir adelante pero
también está mi realidad
muchos amigos me preguntan y yo también
me pregunto por qué sigo dedicando tanto
tiempo al hospital porque voy todos los
martes y jueves
si podría estar dedicando ese tiempo el
sanatorio a la costanera que tanto me
gusta
llevo dos años trabajando adhonorem que
no se le encargó que esto lleva tiempo
hay otras prioridades hay muchos médicos
como vos
espero que tiene más antigüedad aún así
les recomiendo
dediquen tiempo a ayudar a los demás es
muy gratificante en mi caso no se me
moviliza el hecho de ver en el
postoperatorio un nene que me enseña el
movimiento nuevo que logro
mi vida no sería la misma si no hubiera
dedicado tantas horas del hospital
alassia
me hubiera perdido conocer mucha gente
no hubiera salido en el diario de mi
ciudad no conocería la legislatura
provincial
y no estaría acá contándoles mi historia
estas cirugías que les comenté yo no las
invente se realizan hace mucho tiempo en
muchísimos lugares del mundo pero
lamentablemente en escasos hospitales
públicos de argentina
yo defiendo el sistema de salud pública
pero creo que puede ser mejor merecemos
que sea mejor
quiero aprovechar este momento para que
juntos podemos reconocer reconocer a
tantos médicos mejores y más dedicados
que yo que durante muchos años siguen
trabajando y enseñando en hospitales
públicos en malas condiciones
por un sueldo bajo hubo muchos otros
casos como el mío solo por amor al arte
quiero aprovechar este momento para que
juntos podamos pensar
por qué
porque dependemos de el amor al arte de
ciertos médicos para encontrar
excelencia en la salud pública
por qué
si teniendo hospitales muy bien
equipados y universidades muy
reconocidas
una familia sin recursos tiene que
viajar y gastar lo que no tiene para
encontrar solución a su problema de
salud
por qué
un niño debe esperar diez años para
volver a tocar su cara obras algún ser
querido muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]